Bueno, para hablar muy claro,
o sea, coalición Canaria está en contra de la amnistía,
eso está claro,
¿está decidido además en los órganos del partido eh?
En cuanto a la investidura o no de Pedro Sánchez,
pues pues claro no,
pero en primer lugar
no sabemos si el Rey lo VA a designar o no
y en segundo lugar,
no hay ningún tipo de negociación abierto
en estos momentos.
Por lo tanto nosotros nos sentimos con total libertad
para votar lo que
estuvimos convenientes en 1 hipotética investidura.
Y en materia de acuerdo
en Canarias está totalmente desvinculado.
El acuerdo de Canarias es el que se ha alcanzado
en en el gobierno de Canarias,
en cabildos y en
Gran cantidad de ayuntamientos
con el partido popular en Canarias
está totalmente despiculado de de ese apoyo,
entre otras cosas porque somos partidos distintos